[Musique]
quand wilson turtur quand on a demandé à
winston churchill de couper dans les
budgets de l'art et de la culture pour
l'effort de la gueule il a répondu mme
alors pourquoi nous battons nous
certains se demandent à quoi servent les
arts et c'est une question qui a même
une dimension éthique pour des pays qui
font face à des défis comme la santé et
l'éducation et la pauvreté
alors moi je vais vous parler de ma
passion et de mon métier de cinéaste et
vous dire pourquoi je pense que le
cinéma peut et devrait être un
instrument de progrès et de paix pour
répondre aux grands défis de demain
d'abord le cinéma ça permet d'aller
au-delà des préjugés des clichés et de
faire un pont entre les cultures
par exemple il ya quelques années je
suis parti faire un film de surf en iran
alors quand on pense à l'iran pense pas
forcément au surf
surtout que le surf en iran avec les
initiés par des femmes
on était quatre skis une surfeuse
irlande elle monnaye xala de sportive
iranienne déjà pionnière de leur
discipline et moi prêts à immortaliser
le moment
derrière la caméra l'histoire a démarré
sur une intuition parce que je sais pas
pourquoi mais la première fois que j'ai
mis le pied en iran je me sens très bien
il y avait quelque chose qui
m'interpellait dans ce pays c'était
peut-être le décalage entre ce qui passe
que j'imaginais ce que je voyais et
j'avais eu l'intuition qu'il allait se
passer quelque chose de grand et je
savais aussi que en étaient les
premières que jamais personne n'avait
encore surfé en iran donc c'était une
belle opportunité
du coup l'intuition s'est transformé en
évidence je dois faire ce film de surf
en iran l'histoire était tellement
insolite et inédite que mon film a fait
le tour du monde et moi avec
alors faire un film c'est pas facile
c'est compliqué faire un film de surf
féminin en iran ça demande un peu de
logistique tout a été difficile et à ce
moment là le cinéma ça vous oblige à
aller au delà de vos limites et à
persévérer mais la réalisation à m'a
pris plus de 8 mois
il a fallu que je pense à tous les
aspects les aspects financiers pour
reproduire le film les aspects
techniques avec un tournage compliqué
les aspects administratifs avec des
autorisations de chine en iran les
aspects logistiques pour envoyer des
planches dans un pays sous sanction est
évidemment les aspects humains et
pendant ces huit mois je me suis je me
suis senti seul trait salle parce que
j'avais l'impression de porter tout
projet sur mes épaules et surtout dans
ces cas là ils sont rares les gens qui
vous pousse à ce type auraient ils sont
très rares au contraire il ya beaucoup
de gens dans l'industrie qui essaient de
me dissuader de faire ce film qui de
toute façon ne rentrera pas dans les
cases alors plus j'avançais et plus je
me retrouvais face à des murs et quand
on est devant beaucoup de murs
l'évidence se transforme en doute et si
je mettais en danger tous les gens qui
viennent avec moi et si on est jeté en
prison par ce concert et si on me
donnait pas mon visa et simon empêchés
de filmer et six personnes s'intéressent
à l'histoire et si j'étais pas fait pour
faire des films
à ce moment là on invente tous les
scénarios et on a beaucoup d'imagination
mais finalement le pire des scénarios
c'était celui de renoncer à mes rêves à
cause de mes peurs elle me réveiller un
matin et me dire et si j'avais fait ce
film de surf en iran alors j'ai mis mes
peurs en veilleuse et j'ai tapé dans les
murs et j'ai bien fait parce que quand
je voulais dire mon film a fait le tour
du monde
il a été récompensé dans de nombreux
festivals internationaux
j'ai reçu un prix j'ai reçu un award
pour le meilleur documentaire star ait
fait ça m'a ouvert beaucoup de portes
professionnellement et la persévérance a
payé parce que maintenant on m'appelle
pour faire des films mais la plus belle
des récompenses quand même c'est celle
que j'ai eue sur place
parce que faire un film et le cinéma
ça permet
de faire tomber les barrières quand on
est arrivés en iran contre toute attente
en hâte et encourager et supporter par
les autorités religieuses locales qui
était plutôt content de voir arriver du
surf sur leurs côtes et qui nous ont
garanti qu'ils allaient assurer notre
protection ce qui était pas mal
du coup on est parti on a exploré la
côte et on a trouvé une vague devint un
village de pêcheurs qui s'appellera
mines et c'est là qu'on a décidé de se
jeter à l'eau pour la première fois
alors on a vite été entourée par des
hommes par les garçons et c'est marrant
parce qu'un garçon qui nous a demandé
s'il y aussi ils avaient droit de surfer
parce que comme il y avait que des
femmes dans l'eau il a cru que c'est un
sport pour les femmes et comme on est
très cool on a dit ok du coup en affaire
fait ensemble en respectant les
consignes de la veille les hommes d'un
côté les femmes de l'autre
sauf que la vague a nous a tous réunis
au même endroit c'est toute la magie est
la beauté de ce sport c'est comme le
cinéma c'est qu'il fait tomber toutes
les barrières alors s'en vouloir
on a brisé une règle est naturellement
la pratique du surf est devenu mixte on
a surfé ensemble pendant une semaine on
a eu des maris qui nous ont demandé de
faire ça fait leurs femmes des papas qui
nous ont demandé de faire ça refait leur
fille et c'est là que j'ai compris
vraiment pourquoi j'avais fait tout ça
pour quoi j'avais tapé dans les murs et
pourquoi j'avais bien fait de suivre mon
intuition plutôt que d'écouter mes peurs
c'était pour vivre ce moment de partage
dans un océan qui ne laisse pas place au
rallye que l'on impose au sol hélas le
cinéma ça sert à capter la beauté
ouais en fait
m
et là
alors que l'on soit spectateurs au
réalisateur
le cinéma ça permet de et alors me l'ont
pas dit quand on est friand
on a toujours cette volonté de ceux trop
fils dans la réalité des autres
on a toujours cette volonté de
comprendre la complexité de la condition
humaine on regarde le monde avec une
perspective avec une ouverture et avec
une disponibilité ce qui sont d'après
les valeurs qui manque à nos sociétés
maintenant qu'ils sont de plus en plus
divisés n'ont pu tourner sur elle-même
moi je pense que si l'on regardait tous
le monde avec un grand angle
peut-être que ça résoudrait quelques
problèmes je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
faire un film parfois ça vient d'une
intuition comme mon film en iran et
parfois ça vient d'une urgence l'urgence
de dire quelque chose
alors quand j'ai appris que des réfugiés
politiques arrivés à quelques kilomètres
de chez moi
après léman tellement de calais il ya
dernière j'ai proposé de leur donner des
cours de français parce que ça faisait
cinq ans que je voyais ces hommes et ces
femmes derrière mon écran de télévision
ça faisait cinq ans que les médias en
parlent et tous les jours et donc que
indirectement il faisait partie du
quotidien des français
et comme je voulais dit moi quand on
fait du cinéma on a envie de comprendre
et de comprendre sans l'intermédiaire
des médias je voulais me faire ma propre
opinion
du coup je suis parti à leur rencontre
et j'ai sympathisé avec l'un d'entre eux
abdi qui est romo d'ethiopie évidemment
tous les deux on a voulu faire un film
sur son histoire
parce que là le cinéma ça sert à
témoigner et à garder en mémoire
on pourra pas dire qu'on ne savait pas a
dit me raconter des choses assez
inconcevable
la réalité dépasse la fiction et il
fallait que les gens sachent il fallait
que ça sorte il fallait vite que ce que
j'entende soit captée par tous
alors quand j'ai pensé au scénario de ce
film j'ai magique il fallait pas
seulement être factuel parce qu'il avait
pour me raconter les prisons libyennes à
méditerranée le traversée du sahara je
pouvais pas l'imaginer parce que j'ai
pas vécue par contre je savais une chose
c'est que n'importe quelle maman partout
dans le monde comprendrait ce que ça
veut dire que de ne plus pouvoir voir
son enfant alors j'y fais ce qui peut
plus faire je suis parti en ethiopie
pour aller voir sa mère et pour lui
apporter un message un message de son
fils qu'elle a pas vus depuis sept ans
et j'ai recueilli les propos d'une maman
forte qui a dit avec des mots très
justes parce que ça signifie que de
manquer son fils il a fallu sept ans à
vie pour arriver en europe dans des
conditions difficiles et pour légaliser
sa situation
il m'a fallu sept heures pour aller en
ethiopie le film est terminé
il n'a pas été facile à faire on n'a pas
toujours été d'accord d'ailleurs mais
bon on l'a fini et maintenant avec le
recul que maintenant que tout est passé
on est vraiment très content d'avoir
mené jusqu'au bout cette collaboration
en cours au mot s'appelle à mr bien et
peut-être que c'est celui ci notre plus
grand défi de demain c'est de se battre
pour que l'art existe parce qu'il est
indispensable
le cinéma ça sert à se divertir bien sûr
mais pas seulement
ça sert à s'exprimer ça sert à
travailler ensemble à faire un pas vers
l'autre à trouver des compromis
ça sert à se révolter ça sert à mieux se
comprendre à effacer les peurs qu'on
peut avoir les uns envers les autres et
du coup ça peut nous aider à mieux vivre
ensemble
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]